it's time to unveil our secret
ingredient that mystery ingredient comes
out and it doesn't matter what it was in
your mind before bartenders remove your
lids Wow it's Croatia the country's top
bartenders converged on Las Vegas to
battle a tower the game create a
signature cocktail using a secret
ingredient to be presented to our
esteemed panel of judges
all before time runs out whoo we have
three of America's best bartenders here
competing for a chance to make it
through to our grand final let's meet
our competitors
my name is Robin Kauffman I'm very
classically driven I like things to be
right on point my name is Lee Pepe what
I love about bartending is classic
cocktails my name is Brian means my
personal style of bartending to make
savory style cocktail welcome bartenders
under the lids in front of you is a
secret ingredient with that secret
ingredient you'll have to make an
unforgettable gin cocktail the winner
will move on to the finals with a chance
to be crowned America's bartender it's
time to unveil our secret ingredient
we're sweating and all I can think of is
what's under this lid you've got your
drink in your mind and then that mystery
ingredient comes out and it doesn't
matter or whatsoever what was in your
mind before bartenders remove your lids
the secret ingredient is full fat Greek
yogurt I was like wow Greek yogurt first
let's can I believe I've used yogurt
before so I guess it was a bit of a
challenge but my mind went somewhere
right away which is a huge relief
actually
bartenders your time starts now
so let me introduce you to the judges
we have been Carlotto David knee paav
and Angelo Sosa I think then they seem
to have a pretty good idea about what
they're trying to achieve and where
they're trying to go straight off the
bat I'm surprised you gotta think on
your feet out there you're trying to
think of the most creative cocktail you
can on the spot that's the point of the
competition I didn't expect Ricky okay
that could potentially just overshadow
the gin so that would be the challenges
for me my mind immediately goes to an
idea which is a nice dosage in peaches
Amontillado sherry which has a nice
nuttiness to it and also a different
sort of acidity there's no obvious way
to utilize this year I really need to
see what they come up with there's no
sort of instant yes I can do that trying
to pair the Greek air of the gins hard
because Bali see there's no Greek yogurt
and Bombay Sapphire so you can't really
relate it to the gin so you have to find
a way they will balance the flavors the
rest the cocktail and still get it to
pull through it's not an easy ingredient
to work with and I've seen that used a
few times in it and it definitely is a
challenge but I definitely think you
know most partners don't have the
opportunity to play with this stuff it's
challenging but that's the whole point
Greek yogurt is not something I normally
play around with behind a bar I'm only
gonna get these other flavors to come
out while still tasting to beat yogurt
Wallsend should really be thinking about
glossing up pretty soon time is racing I
thought for the first half I had lots of
time and then it came like a freight
train guys two minutes two minutes to go
I was definitely not in a good place
with that last minute left you had to
keep it in the second gear you just had
to produce the drink one minutes ago
guys one minute I could see my hands
shaking and I could feel myself sweating
so garnishes are really born right it
could be the difference between winning
and losing hundred percent is that that
extra 1% the cherry on top of the sundae
and garnishes with how they smell how
you can interact with the palate and I
wonder if did they have time to make the
garnishes
it's a very good point 20 seconds to go
20 seconds hey I can feel the tension
I'm glad I'm on this side yeah I had a
few ideas as garnishes and stuff but you
really run out of time very quickly so I
had to just do what I could
five four three two one Austin to step
away from your stations please write
down for the last second talk about
under pressure when the time was out
everybody takes a sigh of relief I
stepped away I looked at the drinks I
loved the way they looked if I could do
it again I'd probably do it a little
better
bartenders great job Robin tell us about
you drink so my cocktails called the
High Noon because when I was a kid we'd
go to France and at lunchtime we'd
always have yogurt after the meal we got
fruit to it and sometimes nuts to it too
so that's why I use the Amontillado
sherry is a nice nutty flavor I use a
lot of round ingredients I have quite a
heavy weight on the palate so that the
gin could cut through and sort of show
itself and the aromatic on the top would
be a nice that's my inspiration for the
cocktail for me personally this is a
drink that I was totally engaged with
and then the star niece just stole the
show and kind of just took away from the
beauty and the essence of that Greek
yogurt Lee congratulations please tell
the judges about your console it's
called breakfast in Vegas gentlemen
yogurt is a breakfast item in my mind
and so is gin I tried to bring together
some citrus a little sweetness for the
yogurt a hint of lavender which hits the
high notes and the botanicals which are
my favorite in the Sapphire and it just
brings the gin right through the yogurt
to the top I think the strawberries was
a very safe move I mean the yogurt
strawberries was you know definitely
easy move um I'm not getting some of the
lavender you mentioned that I would have
liked to see more of that but overall I
think it was a it is a very delicious
and we'll run the cocktail
Brian fantastic job please tell the
judges about your cocktail my cocktail
is called pea brain because one of the
main main ingredients in the cocktail we
actually use snap peas and some shiso
the snap peas adds a little bit of
sweetness I added some gum syrup to
actually bind some of those flavors
together
fresh lemon juice to brighten up the
cocktail threw in some lemon tea oil
some grains of paradise to kind of bring
out some
botanicalls the Bombay Sapphire well
it's the Colo so what are your thoughts
there's a little bit bitter and
ultimately we wanted an imaginative
drink but at the end of the day we all
want to have that balanced cocktail
which is not quite balanced there for me
thank you bartenders phenomenal job the
winner of our semi-final round and
advancing through to our finals is Robin
Robin congratulations thank you
Robins high noon cocktail won today
because his gorgeous presentation and
the anisa aromas that perfectly
highlighted the gym all while keeping
good balance with the difficult texture
of the Greek yogurt well done well done
this guy's gone frizzy to find I was
most afraid of today through the whole
competition and what's going on I don't
want to jinx it but it's over and done
with I can look forward feel good want
to try making this winning Greek yogurt
cocktail at home give it a taste
for more exciting episodes subscribe to
the GQ channel